Oh Samuel lives here and firstly I'd
like to say a massive congratulations to
subscribing to this video series the
information you're gonna get from this
video and from the next four videos to
come
could potentially change your financial
life forever I don't know exactly how
you first heard about me I've been
investing in property for now almost 10
years
I'm the Amazon best seller of this book
buy low rent I which is sold to
thousands of people across the world and
has changed many many lives so what do I
want to talk to you about right now well
this is the first video so this is going
to be hopefully changing your mind on a
few things related to property related
to the economy and then as we go on by
the end of the fifth video you should be
absolutely away some of the topics that
we're going to be covering or HMOs how
to buy property with no money and on
similarly how you can become financially
free in the next twelve months or less
by investing in property and taking
these practical steps that I'm going to
teach you so if that sounds good then
you're in the right place and let's get
started first thing I love address is
the lies that are taught and accepted in
society around finances around property
and ultimately around your future I'm
gonna read a little tiny significant my
book if you've not read this bylaw
Graham hi I would suggest that you
definitely do read it it might be on its
way to you right now in the post I don't
know if you have read it and you like it
then please do kindly leave me an Amazon
with you that would be absolutely
incredible but I made this little
snippet which is titled the seven lies
and some people have found this really
controversial some people have even been
a little bit affected by it but this is
just my opinion and you can chew the
meat spit out the bones but you know
what I'm doing pretty okay so let me
read this when I was at a school if I
told my teachers that I wanted to become
a property investor they even have said
that it was a risky move they would have
told me that if I wanted to Garin
see success then I needed to follow
their system and I'm sure you're
familiar with it it sounds like this one
study hard at school and it's important
you get good grades to go on to
university if you want to be paid well
three get a good job for life
four if you buy a house pay off the
mortgage as quickly as possible
five save as much as you can to store
away safely in the bank six the harder
you work the more money you'll make
seven look forward to retirement because
that's the good life now I'm going to
contradict that slightly now and tell
you what my experience has been over the
last ten years of being a property
entrepreneur and this is what I believe
to be the truth what most people do not
benefit from good grades so it is
controversial to most people who finish
University still struggle to get a job 3
a good job for life doesn't exist for
paying off the mortgage quickly is not
smart 5 your money is shrinking in the
bank 6 some of the poorest people of a
hardest workers 7 if retirement is your
motivation you'll be extremely
disappointed a little bit of a
contradiction to what society have us
believe but that's kind of really the
foundation of this the foundation of
this is that we've been taught from a
young age to work really hard to get
good grades to save up money put it in
the bank and in lots and lots of active
income well the first thing I want to
show you guys is the difference between
and some super bother is some of this
you might already know and some of it
might be quite new to you but the most
dangerous words that you can possibly
say one is I'm gonna do that and then
not do it
- is I already know that but you're not
doing it
so the queue to be successful you is two
things the first thing is you need
knowledge and then what you've got
knowledge to be successful you then need
to take a lot of action so some of the
things that I'm going to be going
through this video series so might be
new some of might you might already know
but the bottom line is I want you to use
all this stuff as a tool and then go and
do it and then when you're super success
when you can send me a nice email or
leave me in the Amazon review okay so
the first thing that you need to get
into your brain there's a property
investor and again people that invest in
property a lot of people that they're
investing for all the wrong reasons it's
all about you know feelings and they've
got all these day all these wrong
reasons so we're going to be going
through that but the first thing in
order to become financially free which
is ultimately what this is about is we
need to understand the difference
between passive and active income so
passive income is money that you earn
every single month whether you work or
not which is what you get from property
there's lots of other things you can get
passive income from systemized
businesses franchise bending machines
network marketing royalties from CDs and
books but I personally think that the
best has an income is from property
active income is the income that you've
been programmed to earn from a child
which is where you work once and you get
paid once not so good so your training
your time for money and that's what most
people work for however you are going to
be working for passive income not active
income and I've done a whole nother
video about financial freedom which you
can watch right here hopefully it just
popped up right there but if the
financial freedom
the definition of financial freedom in
short is when you're passive
is equal to or greater than your living
expenses so when you hit that when your
passive income is equal to or greater
than your living expenses then guess
what you don't need to work anymore if
you don't want to guys I hit this by the
age of 21 okay so this is really not
that difficult because you know you
don't have to be rich to be financially
free your your living expenses could be
two or three thousand pounds a month
which is not a big wage at all but if
you're earning that in passive income
then you're free and then you can start
having some fun so that's the goal
that's the goal for the next 12 months
if you're already financially free then
you can change living expenses to
desired lifestyle but effectively we
need to be building this passive income
up so let me show you something really
interested as we get started because a
lot of people say to me you know what
are the best types of properties what
should I be buying so obsessional very
interesting if you were to do what most
people say you should do and save lots
of money to put it in the bank and let's
say you saved up a whole lot of money
you put it in the bank
of course interest rates aren't very
high so you're not going to be getting a
lot of interest so you're gonna need to
put a lot of fifty thousand pounds in
the bank in order to get some decent
interest again the interest is so low
you can have to wait an awful long time
for that fifty thousand pounds to go up
so let's say you wait ten years
so you put fifty thousand pounds in it
back great good move you wait ten years
and you don't spend a penny and you wait
for it to appreciate Lord you know what
I did this presentation in front of a
group of bankers and I was terrified
but when I said this that they all
agreed they wouldn't onto their head and
that is this your fifty thousand pounds
after ten years will now be worth not 51
not fifty two thirty six thousand pounds
how so
money depreciates in value every single
year every single month every single day
your money is shrinking in the bank
which is bad news
however it's bad news for the typical
person because most people have got
money in the bank or all have ins but
first it's not bad news at all because
if you put that same 50,000 pounds into
a house or guess what based on history
history tends to repeat itself money in
houses houses built up in value other
times now this is how people get rich by
mistake I myself have made over a
quarter of a million pounds just in the
last 18 months I'll say that again a
quarter of a million pounds in the last
18 months I made by mistake I didn't
even try and make it it was just that
the depreciation on the houses came with
that money and they say on average and
you may disagree with this number
exactly again this isn't my opinion my
opinion doesn't really count very much
this is history
they stayed that property prices in
England they're in a very small island
where we've got the shortage of houses
and we've got people literally fighting
to get into the country and wherever the
supply and demand this happens they say
the property's on average double in
value every 7 to 9 years 7 to 9 years
now you might think oh yeah but what
about this and what about that I think
is 10 working 10 years
ok let's say 10 years on average your
property's double in value every 10
years which means that if you put 50,000
pounds into a house and you wait 10
years it's not gone down to 36 but what
what it may have gone up to 100 but
here's the really cool thing 50,000
pounds is probably
the deposit on laughs and the house
itself is probably closer to around
200,000 25 percent very just what could
be more than 200,000 well tell me what
doubles the deposit on the house or the
house and of course the answer is
perhaps doubles which means you put down
50,000 pounds and after 10 years you now
got 400,000 pounds
we call this leverage and that is how
most people get rich by mistake I mean
literally you get the same two people
they're both of the same job they live
on the same street they went to the same
school with the same qualifications then
the exact same amount of money they even
manage their money the same they both
put aside the same amount one saves up
50,000 the other saves up 50,000 one
puts it in the back and into broke and
wont blitzie the house there's a bridge
and this is why communism didn't work in
fact it seems Jim Rohn who said it
teaches his kids to have two bicycles
want to ride one two rents how difficult
does it get with a little ingenuity and
in the exact same way if we could start
rather than trying to pay off our
mortgage as quickly as possible
save up put money in the bank and we
could manage our money properly and the
money that we put aside we could start
putting it into property investment
deposit deposit deposit deposit buy low
rent high doesn't have to be expensive
in fact we're gonna immediately be
taking on some other videos how to buy
property get your foot in the door and
start gaining from this without starting
with any money at all might sound too
good to be true but you bear with me
you'll see what will happen so that is a
little bit about why I'm so excited
about property why am i standing here
now teaching you this what's what's my
agenda or my agenda
I've got two reasons one when I mean
when I'm effectively retired at 21 and I
could do it I wanted that all the time I
had I was completely financially free
starting out on holiday
different stuff and you know what it's
boring making it on your own all my
friends were at university or a dead-end
jobs I'm financially free but no one
wanted to come on holiday with me and
it's boring so I started teaching number
two is by absolutely loving it's such a
massive burst when people message me and
say I saw your video I came to property
investors crash course I read your book
and I've just done XYZ changed my life
bought a house with no money with my
wife just left work I get a buzz from
that so there's always going to be
cynical people I'm thinking you know
what do you do your own research this is
what I've learned from trial and error
and from spending a lot of money on
training programs I'm financially free I
live a real good life now and this is
the foundation of it so don't believe
four seven lawyers I've really copy of
this if you haven't already and watch
out for my next video coming very very
soon
[Music]